je descends gauche je tombe sur toi je
vais en egypte me met des bâtons dans
les roues
maintenant tu m'empêche d'envahir la
bretagne tu a clairement décidé de me
pourrir la vie
je sais comme ça ces aventures d'astérix
et pour les aventures de césar les
aventures d'astérix
là
sujet
je sais que je ne peux pas refuser le
césar parce que c'est irréel le film la
partition du film est écrit de manière
efficace très drôle neuf jours marc
hongrie veut mieux
incroyable moi je crois bien que j'ai la
côte avec les dieux mais le rôle bien
écrit je trouvais que c'était amusant de
jouer un personnage qui n'existe pas
donc une bande dessinée et qui a été
inventé et qui aurait pu tout à fait se
trouvait dans cet organe d'albums
d'astérix compagnons sont loi il est
facile de deviner avec son baladeur
moi j'étais impressionné au départ de
rencontrer gérard depardieu et de
rencontres c'est catherine deneuve par
exemple mais les ça dure deux secondes
quoi il vous met à l'aise dans la
seconde gt après voilà l'escaut ce qui
est impressionnant c'était voilà c'est
de tourner pendant cinq mois de
de porter ce film pendant cinq mois
c'est vrai que moi je n'avais jamais
vécu
alors moi je fais goudurix c'est le
neveu du chef du village en fête qui a
amené en vacances chez astérix obélix
parce que ils veulent en faire un homme
alors bon voilà c'est un dragueur et
puis il va se faire et un peu peureux
violence est vraiment l'expression des
faits que je te dis là un moment c'est
très humain quel est votre potion
magique
la potion magique si la passion
l'admiration pour cette langue
absolument sublime qui s'appelle la
langue française ma posture magie beaux
jours des fois j'ai pas vraiment de
potion magique malheureusement j'ai revu
en hausse
ce
beaucoup